[Music]
women are being trafficked children are
being trafficked
they just don't wake up saying I want to
be a prostitute this is happening in our
neighborhoods in our communities it
really hides in the shadows I'm scarred
and I'll be scarred for life
it is modern-day slavery I knew I was
for sale
America has a growing sex trafficking
problem and Atlanta is one of the hot
spots I hope is that how dangerous these
streets are mm-hmm yeah but it's best
for you to be armed yeah because you
never know
Casey McClure is a street outreach
worker showing us a notorious area on
the outskirts of the city she's pregnant
she's a date light to drive how often
will she be forced to have sex probably
say five or six times at least a day per
day minimum
you know the pimp will make sure you
need to go make this he can feed her
here - then
make her look you gotta go self you
gotta go make me some money because it's
so much like they have to be drugged out
to do what they do can I give you a gift
basket okay she hands out toiletries and
her phone number to the women and girls
working here you're welcome
what's your name Queen I'm Casey nice to
meet you so you love your hat
we're with for Sarah how are you I'm
Casey
and we're just doing outreach and if you
ever need anything you can call that
number okay I love your tattoos they're
pretty she looked young she did yeah but
she could be 18 or she could be 16 we
don't know that she definitely looks
very young and she it could be two that
she's fresh you know like she's freshly
on the streets once they're trapped in
the illegal sex industry it's a brutal
often short life they're getting beat up
we've had girls who have other teeth
knocked out they don't have any teeth
you know how can they get off the
streets and go get a decent job when
they can't even smile
No all right hello but sometimes Casey
makes a connection a 16 year old girl
calls for help can you go there tonight
a safe house is arranged it's exhausting
work but Casey's past drives her on how
do you keep doing it why won't you know
like once like it's like everything I've
been through like the abuse being
molested running away quitting school
using drugs and to see where I am today
and just see that that could have been
me you don't mean like why not
[Music]
backstage at the pink ponies strip club
the dancers get ready for another shift
Atlanta has a thriving adult
entertainment industry and those in it
are easy targets for traffickers here
though the woman in charge is determined
to make sure no one is working against
their will we have things in our
application things that I can't overly
disclose because I don't want everybody
to know all of our tricks of helping
protect the girls but there's a lot of
things even from the front door a
protective measures that we do stop
pimps trying to get into the club stop
pimps from getting into the club and
stop
pimps trying to get their girls into the
club because once a girl gets in the
club then it can further spread a
solicitation and recruiting other girls
as well
five major motorways converge on this
city making it easy to move and hide
trafficking victims as a network of
lorry drivers called truckers against
trafficking is trying to stop that we're
out here 24 hours a day we're we're
places that this is going on the truck
stops the rest stops when a truck comes
in for delivery the night before and
he's sitting there taking his ten hour
break there are people that are bring
girls to customers and work them right
there in the parking lot
Steven Richardson like thousands of his
colleagues has learned to spot the signs
and call a national hotline these girls
approach you in the truck you know it's
simple questions you can ask them to
find out and the main thing is uh do you
even know where you are if they don't
know where they are if they look drugged
look for tattoos showing markings that
they belong to someone they they mock
these girls like like they're pieces of
material it's grief just let out grieve
to me when you could get up and make an
honest day's living but you'd rather do
it on the sweat of someone else's back
especially young kids that's that's just
disgraceful
Atlanta's Airport is the busiest in the
world and useful cover for traffickers
flight attendant Donna Hubbard helps
train people in the industry to watch
out for potential victims and like so
many of the women who told us their
stories she is also a survivor I was
traded for guns
I was traded for weapons I was traded
for drugs
I was traded when it just to discipline
me sometimes to punish me I was beaten
and left for dead three times people
always think you know why don't why
doesn't she just leave why don't they
run away where would you go and how
would you get away with everything that
you have of course you you will leave
everything and some women do they leave
their children behind they leave
everything behind to live and that
at the last point of my life when I
realized I was not gonna be able to get
away from them I wanted to live and I
wanted my children to live and I wanted
a better life so my way out was to go to
prison I had been arrested 27 times I
went to jail seven times and that last
time I knew that I was going to have to
go to prison or they were never gonna
leave me alone I made sure that my
children were safe and when we were
arrested I did not allow them to bail me
out
[Music]
sex trafficking overwhelmingly affects
young people often children in Georgia
charity campaigns like this one focus on
reducing the demand for child sex a
problem made worse by the thousands who
visit this area for its many big sports
events and conventions the scale of the
issue is hard to measure but the figures
that do exist are startling the latest
research that we have says that in on
any given night in the state of Georgia
300 plus or minus kids are being sold
for sex if you want to know what a
purchaser of sex looks like it looks
like you it looks like me the statistics
tell us that the arrest records tell us
that the FBI's field office here is home
to the nation's largest anti child sex
trafficking task force supervisory
special agent Erik Pauly is grappling
with a crime that's constantly morphing
moving online crossing borders and
hiding in the shadows it's money money
is there is the motivator here these
pimps are in traffickers look to exploit
children and adults primarily for the
financial benefit involved in it the
average age of entry for children that
have entered this lifestyle is as for as
approximately fourteen years of age with
their vulnerable children and these
traffickers feed off of that
vulnerability much like any predator
does a term that is commonly used as
throwaway children what happened to you
Elena beretti was one of those throwaway
children first trick I returned I was 15
years old I also run away from
from home parents wrong drugs and I
eventually ran into an actual pimp and
that was when I was about 17 years old
she's making a mockery at you if you got
a bother you and she ain't get no money
you're making a joke on yourself her
pimp went by the name of Scooby he
groomed and trafficked Elena
photographing and marketing her for sex
with men who knew she was young you have
to be a strong person to live that
lifestyle it's it's not made for
everybody everybody thinks oh it's easy
you're just laying on your back you know
it's just sex
and but it's not just sex it's you're
opening your soul to every John you
sleep with at the time did you have any
sense that you were a child and he was
sexually exploiting you the commercial
gain at the time no when I look back on
it now no I don't think that I I think
you know I was 17 I was a baby
eventually she decided to run and Scooby
ended up in prison
although Elena didn't testify at his
trial was it hard to leave it was it's
very hard why because you've been with
somebody that you've put your all into
somebody that has taught you how to
survive make a living I mean I made more
money than most lawyers doctors so it's
like how do you turn on somebody that
has taught you so much and has put food
in your mouth
showed you a hustle and do you did
develop feelings for them
would you now consider yourself free of
that life no I fight it every day every
day this isn't just a problem in Atlanta
it's estimated that across this country
apart from all the adults involved up to
300,000 American children are at risk of
being trafficked every year tremendously
profitable for criminals and with
devastating effects the victims it's
being called America's new slavery